audiences have seen the first footage of
the happy time murders and the response
was explosive I wet myself in
anticipation good time for you and it
can't be unseen
now we know the purple carpet doesn't
match the drapes
WTF no seriously what the actual you
want me to pull my gun no unless you're
talking about you Wiener so blue
inappropriate this [__] wild someone out
there is killing puppies wait wait
what this movie seems stupidly good is I
want to think of this the happy time
murders
they'll tell you that it's cool that
everyone's doing it that you can stop
anytime you want they'll say it makes
food taste more delicious that makes sex
even sexier that it'll take the edge off
but here's what nobody will tell you
nobody is what nobody will tell you what
the hell are you doing here you're the
reason we're making this video oh really
well that's very flattering
uh-huh rated R
you
I love singing and dancing hi folks
[Music]
[Applause]
50 Cent's out suck your dick
well it's a great price it almost makes
me wish I had a dick for you to suck
dick that is yes you were the most
decorated officers in this department
what do you see
robbery gone wrong to me this wasn't a
robbery this was a hit someone out there
is killing puppet I'm a woman that's
okay good time for you we're gonna catch
the bastards who did these murders
because bodies are gonna start piling up
doing the best damn cops I've ever seen
I'll have your badge for this I'm in the
[__] FBI oh yeah what's that stand
for [__] big it's crazy I'm crazy
[Music]
Oh God are you alright diamond this pure
exist I'm not doing this do it
[Music]
oh sorry about your dead human friend
Phillip is silly
he's servicing a client is that what I
think it is
[Music]
you